boa noite a todos
an como eu já me apresentou sua opinião
brenner em primeiro lugar eu gostaria de
agradecer a comissão organizadora pelo
convite e pelo desafio como oriali
deve tá acostumado a gente está muito
acostumada da aula para alunos de
medicina e falar de artigos para o
colega mas isso aqui é um desafio muito
grande
vou começar apresentando então e
apresentar minha formação que eu acho
que é uma parte muito importante da
nossa na nossa vida eu de novo hamburgo
no rio grande do sul e foi me formei em
medicina em 2004 vão fazer 15 anos já na
fundação faculdade federal de ciências
médicas de porto alegre cirurgia geral
no sedã no hospital governador celso
ramos em florianópolis e depois logo o
cirurgião oncológico na santa casa nessa
formação foram 11 anos de formação a
santa casa é o maior complexo hospitalar
de porto alegre compostos por de sete
centros hospitalares em 2010 logo depois
da residência em busca de trabalho a
gente veio para em cascavel e desde
então o trabalho no seu outro eu tô com
o cirurgião oncologista e principalmente
na área de cirurgia hepáticas
fiz a minha especialização o título em
2012 e no mesmo ano comecei a da aula
aqui na fag a parte mais importante do
estudo é a minha família que me dá
suporte e é meu ponto de apoio para
todos esses desafios
bom o tema consciência eu fui procurar
no dicionário a definição para me ajudar
e me inspirar e no meio da definição da
palavra bom senso que eu acho que a
coisa mais importante tanto na medicina
e como nosso dia a dia sem bom senso e
quem não vai para lugar nenhum
principalmente nos tempos de hoje que
tudo é uma guerra né
ninguém pode falar nada que tudo é
problema eu acho que o bom senso é uma
palavra muito importante nesse tempo de
consciência
e pra montar essa palestra eu pensei que
eu posso fazer que com com cirurgião
oncologista posso fazer para mandar uma
mensagem para vocês não sendo um assunto
médico não sendo um artigo uma discussão
cirurgia
então eu resolvi mostrar minha rotina
que começa cedo às sete e meia da manhã
pelo hospital com meus alunos passando
visita discutindo casos e reexaminar do
paciente evento exames e decidindo qual
vai ser a nossa rotina para o resto do
dia após a visita a gente vai atender o
ambulatório do sul de oncologia o sion
que é um centro de música com do sul a
gente recebe muitos pacientes e tem
muito movimento de isso ea gente atende
dando auxílio os alunos para aprender e
ajudar os pacientes nesse tempo da manhã
também eu divido os horários com meu
consultório à tarde então todas as
tardes a gente tem em cirurgia no centro
cirúrgico e definir o resto da das
condutas né
bom é o qual é o papel em o objetivo do
oncologista no dia-a-dia nessa nessa
rotina que eu tenho que fazer
a principal parte é prevenir né os
exames de rotina e explicar para os
pacientes o que faz mal
por exemplo o exame de colo de útero uma
monografia aquela coisa que a maioria
das pessoas já deveriam saber mas a
gente tem que dá ênfase e tentar
proteger os pacientes diagnosticar o
câncer não é identificar a doença ela
começa pela parte mais importante que é
a simbologia escutar o paciente examinar
o paciente dá valor para suas queixas às
vezes uma coisa simples pode ser muito
importante ver os exames e montar o
diagnóstico a partir do diagnóstico todo
mundo acha que parece mágica acabou o
problema mas é aí que começa o nosso
verdadeiro trabalho né
planejar está já que é uma palavra que
foi infeliz não é estagiária está guiar
que é saber quanto de tumor que o
paciente tem com o nível da doença para
onde está indo o tumor e planejar e
decidir o que é melhor o paciente de
tratamento e cada hoje em dia está cada
vez mais específico e mais
individualizado tratamento e saber que
tipo de tratamento aquele paciente
precisa ea quarta parte que eu votei não
menos importante é o cuidado que é
cuidar do paciente não aquela parte do
cuidar do pós operatório dos cinco dias
até alta clínica
a gente está lá né mas é cuidar o
segmento o paciente vai nos acompanhar
de cinco a dez anos eu sempre brinco no
consultório e se tinha um casamento se
vocês não querem não me querem não
adianta nós vamos passar o resto da vida
brigando então é bom que seja um
casamento bom para os dois lados não é o
segmento vai ser durante no mínimo 10
anos cuidados paliativos são aqueles
pacientes graves né
a gente tem que ficar controlando a
doença dentro do que ele precisa se
precisa de medicação para a dor
você tá com algum sintoma mais grave e
no final as medidas de conforto existe
um termo inglês muito usado que é best
suporte e quer que aquele medida na
beira do leito na beira da morte dá
conforto para as famílias cuidar
é uma parte tão importante quanto as
iniciais
então ficou um pouquinho de segurado mas
só vai funcionar a dividir a
apresentação em três casos para tirar
alguma mensagem para vocês
então esse caso eu montei então
obviamente eu não vou identificar os
pacientes então é seu caso um que eu
botei harley davidson e logo vocês vão
entender por que é é um paciente que foi
meu paciente faz uns dois anos
um colega a dentista um cão outra sua
dívida ativa trabalhando a esposa era
cardiologista numa cidade próxima de ver
o meu consultório procurar com o tumor
de vias biliares e fígado muito avançado
um paciente com um prognóstico terrível
já tinha lido sobre a doença e sabia que
ele ia viver de seis a nove meses com
sorte fazendo tratamento com um cirurgia
e quimioterapia e em todos os cuidados
possíveis
e foi em um paciente que eu conversei
muito com ele era uma pessoa muito
querida e um dia eu estava conversando
no centro na área da quimioterapia ele
me mostrou foto de celular deus nossa
que legal tem uma raiva eu sempre quis
ter um de nós ele disse essa é minha
raiva ea gema motter amarela cor de
ouvir toda moto tem que ter um nome dele
era gema e ele disse eu estou
pretendendo comprar uma tonelada morando
uma uma moto nunca descido deu pra mim
tá esperando o que eu tenho a minha na
garagem nunca sei se eu vou usar aquilo
foi um tiro
eu subi no no meu consultório e no mesmo
momento eu comprei a moto
isso mostra que a gente não pode deixar
nossos sonhos produzir as seguintes
sempre que a gente vê uma oportunidade a
gente tem que agir
a gente merece ser recompensado pelos
nossos esforços
então isso me marcou muito excesso esse
sou eu essa é a minha moto ea gente tem
que merecer os nossos recompensas também
o segundo caso eu banquei com o caso dos
pequenos detalhes porque a gente está
tão envolvida em cirurgia e planejamento
e aula e ea palestra e esquece das
pequenas coisas nessa paciente não essa
paciente mas a paciente desse caso é uma
paciente de 36 anos e ela tinha um tumor
de cólon e junto de outro que operei há
um ano e meio atrás
operei fiz a retirada total do útero
radioterapia quimioterapia e em tudo
parecia que estava perfeito
sete meses depois recebi da doença no
local
examinei fizemos ressonância e como a
gente já tinha adiado e operado não têm
alternativa senão recuperar paciente foi
operada saiu bexiga intestino todo né
vagina paciente ficou mutilada mas a
princípio sem doença e ela bem ela com a
cabeça boa dizendo se eu quero ficar
viva e foi indo ea doença recente vôo e
nesse momento eu chamei a família e
disse olha gente eu não tenho mais nada
cirúrgico para oferecer a não ser nós
manter em quimioterapia para tentar
segurar a progressão dessa doença e foi
indo alguns meses acompanhando e faz
umas três semanas e ainda estava
pensando que eu ia apresentar para vocês
aqui ela voltou voltou na maca caquética
condor que não conseguia ter controle de
jeito nenhum
dor de não parar quieta de revirar na
marca e eu levei ela precisa de cirurgia
eo anestesista não faça um bloqueio ela
bloqueio anestésico para cobertura de
dor e eu vou me dedicar e ela vai ficar
internada e daí no outro dia de manhã eu
cheguei para a visita usando anos já
passei disse muito obrigado
essa foi a primeira noite que eu durmo
inteira em 35 dias
então por isso que eu voltei os pequenos
detalhes
essa noite que ela dormiu não vai contar
um dia a mãe d
para ela não vai contar um dia de mais
de sucesso pra mim no tratamento mas ela
fez toda diferente diferença para
paciente naquele momento então eu acho
que quando a gente planeja as nossas
coisas não sei se alguém vai fazer
medicina aqui ou se alguém tem negócio
projetos eu acho que os mínimos detalhes
são importantes
cada detalhe vai contar as vezes não o
resultado final mas naquele momento do
planejamento vai ser importante
o terceiro carro caso o lugar mais
bonito do brasil há o nome do caso é
guerreira colorada que muito propício
para a noite de hoje é uma noite de
final né e eu estou aqui vendo me
corroendo por dentro por não estar lá
mas eu já tinha assumido compromisso
então resolvi permanecer a essa paciente
é uma boa paciente há sete anos e ela me
acompanha chegou já com diagnóstico com
doença estádio clínico 4 que é um tumor
de cólon com metástase no fígado já eu
operei essa paciente em nove vezes
nesses sete anos e vocês devem ter nossa
são olhar deve ter acabado não
ela tá certo com os amigos dela fazendo
um churrasco e se preparando para o jogo
ela é uma advogada ej pêra colorada e tá
sempre focada na doença dela
todos os dias ela vem me perguntar
alguma coisa nova saiu uma droga nova
vamos esperar vamos ressecar metástase
ela sabe quase mais que o da doença já
não tem mais o que discutir
ela praticamente conduz o caso ea então
eu escolhi esse caso pra finalizar para
mostrar que o foco é tudo em casa e
quando minha esposa decidimos nossas
coisas também precisam manter o foco
o foco é tudo quando a gente tem um foco
a gente vai longe e essa paciente que
foca na cura
ao saber que dificilmente ela vai ficar
curada mas ela segue a vida dela ela
trabalha ela não não pede nada pra
ninguém está sendo focada e eu acho que
a paciente tinha mais tempo tratando
disso que estou trabalhando aqui
das que estão com doença ativa é claro
tem paciente que o acompanha ainda mais
em tratamento eu acho que ela então como
mensagem final
a primeira é que rené não pode desistir
nossos sonhos e não pode postergar eles
tanto assim aponta que a gente não tem
mais tempo para fazê los né
o tempo é finito então não vão ficar
olhando aquele negócio está no nosso
alcance não vou deixar para depois
tem que realizar a outro mensagem que os
detalhes fazem toda a diferença
os pequenos detalhes são importantes
prestem atenção a cada passo
o cara tá enxergando lá atrás no final e
não olha a pedra no meio do caminho
então tem que prestar atenção e prestar
muita atenção nos detalhes e a última
lógica o foco e determinação
eu sempre falo para meus alunos que
persevera se triunfar aço
não adianta ficar aqui fazendo uma
faculdade sentar na cadeira sem estudar
você não precisa se não fizerem o curso
quem faz o curso o aluno vai estudar se
não focar se não fizer uma residência se
não correr atrás ela não vai cair no seu
colo
eu acho que montando tudo isso a gente e
com o tema consciência eu acho que ia se
conscientizado essas pequenas coisas vão
fazer grande diferença na vida de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]